know i see you around i've seen you
around los angeles you work here in los
angeles you shoot your show here in los
angeles but you were shooting this movie
in new york city yes was that okay
what's it i mean it's quite a different
environment to shoot in it is i love
shooting in new york city you see all
kinds of stuff all kinds of crazy stuff
right because in la i don't know i feel
like in los angeles people are more used
to it maybe so they stay out of your way
whereas in new york you just feel like
you're in everybody else's way yes all
the time well it's in la they you're
it's like oh that's a movie and it's an
industry town and everyone kind of
everyone's so savvy oh they're going for
the wide shot i better go around this
exactly but when you're in new york it's
an oddity if you're making a movie it's
like wow they're making a movie
completely and i totally understand it
we are in everybody's way we're throwing
a wrench into everybody's day so we were
shooting
this movie a bit of it in chinatown
so i was in chinatown waiting around a
bit bored because you're always bored
when you're shooting a movie and you're
always waiting around doing nothing so i
was on the phone and all of a sudden i
hear this guy
like screaming screaming at me in
mandarin or cantonese i don't know i
don't speak either you really should
know the difference i should know
how insensitive of you not to know the
difference between cantonese and
mandarin i do know that the man was
definitely chinese and it was not
english when he was yelling and he's
yelling at you why was he yelling at me
well i wasn't sure at first so i began
yelling back as
one does yeah and then i realized that
he was yelling at me based on his hand
gestures because i was standing in the
doorway of his restaurant
loitering yes not cool i apologized i
backed off i went to my trailer about an
hour later
still waiting around still doing nothing
but this time i'm kind of staying close
to home so i don't piss anybody else off
yeah and i see this guy the same guy the
yelling guy in this park across the
street from where my trailer is he's
with his friends and they're having a
nice time they're all giggling he
clearly likes these people way more than
he liked me
and he's with his friends he's hanging
in the parking lot having a nice time
we're in chinatown but it was also the
summer very hot very muggy very smelly
and garbage day yeah again in chinatown
sure so the streets are littered with
big garbage bags full of what i assume
is old chinese food just baking in the
sun sure which is the other thing that i
kind of marvel about in new york which
are the rats the size and the population
of the rats yeah you almost get used to
it i lived in new york a long time and
you just see these massive rats i do not
get used to it they come right at you
they come right at you it's like the
natural order is all screwed up you have
to avoid the rats yeah the rat's
avoiding you so out of the corner of my
eye i see the biggest rat i've ever i
mean bigger
than you
wow that's a big rash
a massive the biggest rat you've ever
seen and it runs right towards this guy
who was yelling at me and it doesn't
stop or change directions it runs up
what up the man the man who was yelling
at you it ran up his chest to his chest
and by his face and he's trying to get
rid of the rat and he finally launches
it off of him it was like a waking
nightmare it was horrible it went like
for his throat
and
the
really strange part about it was that
his friends and this guy his reaction
was to kind of laugh it off like it was
no big deal like it was a pretty
positive reaction to this
he shoves the rat away and then they go
right back to chatting right back that
was some rat that attacked myself
exactly and this is the guy that
screamed at me for standing in the
doorway
and he's perfectly all right with a rat
in his face
and so that was my
moment i would take that very personally
well yeah you were like get out get out
come to me
he's a beautiful man who uh
thought i was a million times more
disgusting than a rat